this is the visitor and the visitor is
Finn's dad just pick a deadbeat as usual
there you go yeah Jason you wash your
arm totally did this is right you're
right of me to know the truth I swear
and yes so the comet is apparently not a
comment it's the it's this ship that has
what are you gonna just comet people is
that what they were called
yeah that's what Finn called them that's
not it
they're not it's not their official
whatever he just called him that because
it's like oh I thought that wasn't
comment yeah but it also happens with
what you would call Finn having this
dream that we're like baby him is
leaving him to this comment that looks
like a sperm he yeah I guess he was just
doing that he was sleep walking
right cuz I yeah I was thinking like
that was still part of the dream but
then sorry Amy I'm like oh no I guess he
actually just walked that you know in
his sleep
oh yeah bet your time you can do that
and yeah it comes across these little
creatures that kind of look like snow
men they remember those squeeze toys oh
the ones were like their ears and nose
gonna yeah okay all right what's that
little white thing isn't one of the
Final Fantasy games yeah like the little
red nose I think that's my mom yeah the
mugs I never believed the game use my I
always bear those from the commercials
that's the only thing I can remember
from Final Fantasy games are fun that's
always I can't do role I can't do our
PJs it's just like would you like to hit
him down like just head up I'm Way too
impatient market ice probably the newer
once then that's all the newer once more
our our Mikey you actually jump around
and do 13 is more that way don't play 13
3 like lightning returns us terror I
just know those are like the most like
the biggest hit or miss games ever
because they let's see people talking
about like listening to
Jemison so but yeah you got these little
snowmen creatures and Finn's dad is
apparently just kind of in charge mommy
makes up the story about the tree spirit
which even they kind of don't believe
they're just kind of really nice yeah
and they're just looking for kind of
just something nice to do and just to
quote-unquote help out and stuff and so
they kind of get abused by this guy but
they seem kinda happy I guess it's hard
to say um it's kind of like me they just
don't know anything else maybe I don't
know because we don't know their past
and it looks like Finn's dad is once
again gonna take off literally and you
know he's gonna leave everybody behind
and he gets a little bit of his
backstory he's on a banana boat all
these creatures tried to kill him and
that's it then we don't really get much
out so we don't even really see if
that's the damn fighting it over and we
know that could be the mother works it's
not even true yeah or it's just made up
there on a banana boat with a tiger
I guess it's adventure time I believe
anything but it's also his dad so who
knows I mean why would he even go with
the effort to make up a lie about that
but then again that get me the truth is
just so interesting it's like no I can't
tell him he's just an ass yeah could be
always that possibility so so he's gotta
leave these little snowmen to blow up
and die thing goes and saves them and
then just starts carrying them all to
the to his place and says when we get to
the tree house I'll do the talking and
just kind of leaves there um and even
he's kind of like picking up the
questions that weren't answered at the
end it's like comment dreams are weird
so maybe there's still a comment you
know could still be coming and maybe
that's just a you know that would make
more sense because the Lynch was seems
to be tied to the comment even you say
account looks like him and that when we
first saw it and then even in the dream
it kind of looks like he's on
calm it almost or something it's like
all fiery and flamey and stuff at
countless oculus in space so I mean
maybe not maybe I'm just seeing what
wasn't there but so that would make more
sense that just explain why it's
whatever the time frame is wrong and why
it was off course and stuff like that I
was gonna hit Mars but yes to all these
questions of where what are those little
snowman
where did Finn's dad go how they come
across them how did he pilot this thing
that suddenly looks like a comet
so yeah kind of all these questions no I
think they were there when he landed
that was their village and everything
normally oh that's why he's saying oh
the trees fair and they say okay we must
have forgotten to believe that pretty
fast well they seem remembered they're
like would you believe it well not
really we just like to help but what he
called them comet people though because
in fact they came but but they did not
so they don't have any connection up to
that thing at all
Oh get into Martin none of that stuff
okay it felt like he had a connection
with them for a while now he's like you
know yeah look see they love it I
scratch him they like it they hug it's
at me see my kid but he was walking for
two days - so maybe just within those
two days he got that connection yeah so
I guess so alright um yeah you're right
know that what makes sense why they were
I was gonna say like Mandy set up there
pretty fast so they were probably there
for a long time it's just that thing
came down and destroyed everything
um yeah even like that ship is kind of
in the shape of like a face and in
Kennedy's weird eyes and like a little
you're almost like that it counts like
that Batman helmet from Batman versus
Superman like the metal one kind of
you're missing nothing trust me but yeah
it's a it's you know it's because right
after the last view log we got talking
just like really fast about religion oh
yeah and this episode I feel very much
kind of has like a religious tie to it
so it's kind of hard not to address that
um I mean I don't know just kind of the
even if they do or don't believe it they
kind of just want to do what they feel
it
helping out and is right and good I
don't know if this guy can't just came
down I guess we can do that you need
religion or a god-like figure in order
to do good things
ork you just do good things because it's
maybe the right thing to do but there's
also can I like how they're they're not
ruh they're like I don't believe it it's
fine it's fine you know even though it's
like you know could it be true
probably not but you know like they're
just so nice yeah they're just so humble
they're just like you know eyes it's
fine they'll just help out until you
know they blow up
yeah be much um so uh no I thought
what's interesting I guess I was hoping
for a little bit more with the return of
Finn's dad because I feel like we kind
of did the deadbeat dad story already
healed up very well yeah uh you know now
they comes back they just kinda do it
again I was kind of hoping like I know
something else would come of that cuz I
remember why I saw him again I'm like oh
well I wonder where they're gonna go
from here because it's like you kind of
feel like you did that story arc and
he's kind of let go and then he comes
back it's like oh we're this gonna lead
I legitimately don't know where you can
go with this story and yeah they just
can't repeat the whole thing again so um
I I don't know like it's it was alright
I'm curious where these things are gonna
fit in if they're gonna be like this be
continuing you know like part of the
story they're just everyone's laughing
just gonna see a little snowman running
around yeah like that so yeah I thought
was alright oh what'd you think of it I
I liked it um I liked it Finn was
finally able to in a sense confront his
father and be like hey what was going on
I have all these questions I want
answered and even as the answer is
immuno if they're true or not yeah and
you see again kind of going to the you
know nature versus nurture type thing
with how scummy his dad is and how
manipulative and how much he doesn't
care for anyone else but himself
when how kind of like smart but not
smart he
is to like he's smart enough to know how
to manipulate but not smart enough to do
it in a way where it's like he's always
gonna be in a good place he's always on
the run or he's always in trouble or
something like that and that there's
always something I see with a lot of
people that need to lie a lot is that
there's kind of no end game there's no
finish line something just sort of keep
going you know cuz that people like
everybody lies
you know but you know they do it in
little chunks or sometimes bigger chunks
to get to a point where it's like you
don't have to lie yeah you know so you
can be relaxed and gone whether you get
what you want but there are people that
are just addicted to it and addicted to
making up just over and over and
over and it is just always so
self-destructive oh you know because you
just it gets to a point where you you
know can they even figure out what the
truth is you know they even though and
yeah I feel very much that's what he is
he is canvas compulsive liar and you
know people always say there's like an
inside you're a compulsive liar but it's
like it's a legit thing and it's very
destructive you know cuz I mean it can
it can get you friends very fast but it
can lose them not just it can lose them
both slowly and quickly but usually
forever like it just loses a friend
forever because they catch on that it's
like you just never stop yeah you know
cuz people don't want to constantly lie
you know they want to live in a point
where you know they can you know relax
in the truth if they want to know what
the truth is and realize so much you're
not gonna necessarily have a good handle
on the truth you know is practically
impossible so yeah I do like how fin fin
makes the choice to send him off even
though he's kind of saying hey you want
to come with you again and finally was
just saying another horrible terrible
thing he just pushes the button and
sends him off I mean face instantly goes
to happy yeah like oh that was good like
yeah I need to do that and fin fin being
brought up by you know Jake's parents or
his you know Finn's parents in a sense
it's that whole thing if like look at
how good Finn turned out hmm you know he
didn't go down this
path of manipulation and not caring for
anyone else
Finn is just a good person overall he
has hatred towards his father he has
questions he has abandonment issues
that's why when he goes to his dream
they're used with the baby version of
himself and he's like don't worry I'll
take care of you and he's like please
don't let go he's like no I won't I
never I never have I never will I meant
does he have a little like you know huh
that's actually true yeah like I didn't
know that like you know even he's kind
of shocked at that you know and this is
the kind of thing where it's like yeah
you know he's always he always wants his
father he's always thought about his
father but at the same time it's you
know that whole thing of like yeah you
know you have the abandonment issues but
you learn to cope you learn to deal you
know um being adopted myself you know
I've been asked numerous times what are
you gonna find your birth pants what are
you gonna find your parents
hold on all that stuff and I know that's
how they ask you this so what are you
gonna do it not if you're gonna do it
just when oh yeah oh yeah and root for
me it was that whole thing if it's like
put there my birth parents who cares hmm
you know my parents are the ones who
raised me and took care of me
love warmer hate um you know it doesn't
matter that's who my parents are and my
birth parents are my birth parents no no
and it did end up I did end up meeting
my birth mom and all that stuff but it
was by her actually looking for me so
for me I can look at Finn in the whole
abandonment thing and be like yeah I can
kind of look at it you know when you
find out yeah you're adopted it's like
huh what was that giving up why why
couldn't they take care of me and you
know all that stuff but you can look at
it two ways those jackasses got rid of
me or huh I'm happy in my family hmm you
know and so I think Finn is more the
hole I'm happy in my family I'm
wondering why but I'm not going to hold
it against the person mmm so for me I
like seeing Finn be like bro I'm okay
now you know but two things came in my
head the after is done one is I'm
probably reading too deep into it but
they know the fact that that thing did
look like a sperm I was
I was immediately thinking like man what
does that mean that's like just going my
head why make that look like a sperm and
the only thing I was kind of coming in
my head after it was all done is like
maybe it is kind of like him kind of
being reborn again in letting go of his
father in a sense you know kinda like
now he can really be rid of them he can
kind of start over but that might really
be when that happened at the beginning
yeah it happened at the beta but maybe
like what's gonna become well even him
holding the young self I mean both has
seemed like preludes to you know kind of
a father-son relationship you know or at
least a connection to where you came
from you know kind of thing you know yep
a sperm and then he had the baby version
of him I don't think it was
intentionally supposed to be a sperm
yeah I think so
if you look at any time a comments drum
that's how it's drawn so if you make it
move any other like the little tail and
stuff I know it's a tail I'm just saying
if you take a comment and try to draw it
any other way it won't look like a comet
most the time it's a it's a big ball
maybe just like a little bit of it this
was like a long tail what comments have
you looked at I'll talk about it
cartoons in cartoons I hold like that
cuz I catch all the other way cuz I look
like a sperm somebody that just answered
my own question is that you know I was
watching the second season about what
sorry go on
oh I was watching the second season of
Kimmy Schmidt which is great show you
haven't seen it go watch it but
something that they come across no I
think it's a you I don't like it but
something that they do in the in the
second season without giving too much
away she goes and finds her mother her
birth mother and it's similar to Finn's
dad again without giving away too much
but it's not the exact same thing but uh
it's a similar kind of kind of ending
again that it looks like that was one
thing I was always laughing about when
someone would ask me when are you gonna
go find your birth parents I'm like now
I know in my luck there gonna be someone
in a trailer park and
like I'm your son you got five bucks
second bar sorry but but it's kind of a
similar resolution that Finn has in
there and that's just real saying huh
like that's two of those I've seen now
and I know I've seen even more stories
about you know characters off to find
their parents or parent usually I should
say and you know the parent usually not
being what they want them to be enough
coming to grips and saying like it's
okay and letting go of that and you know
being fine with that and it seems like
you know that's kind of like where there
used to be a lot of different you know
analysis of families like in you know
80s and oh I mean always there's been
alysus of families uh you know like in
the 50s and 40s we like leave the beaver
and stuff like that then we had like all
in the family and Roseanne and Stephanie
it's sort of like oh this is like what
the family is right now when you see
sort of these repeated patterns and it
is interesting I'm seeing the story of
finding the original parent and them not
living up to what they expected but
coming to grips with and being alright
sort of like the new thing and I think
that that's just an interesting thing
that's like lost cuz I see us a couple
times now and it seems like it's not a
bad lesson to teach because I think if
you do find your original pair under
parents and they turn out fine it's like
great I'm sure there's stuff to talk
about and confront but you know they if
you get along great then great there's
no real problem uh you know but if you
don't that yeah it's gonna be a tricky
thing it's a very hard thing so it's one
of those things where I think that even
if not even if you're not a kid that's
gone through that it's good to show
stories where this is happening to show
that hey there are other kids and people
adults that go through this and that
there is kind of this there's a lot
going on there's a lot to process and
there's a lot to work through and it's
good to understand that it's good to
have empathy for it you know so it's
it's one of those things I feel like I'm
seeing more and more in and Leasing TV
shows and it's interesting it's just
interesting how much more that's coming
to the forefront now where it's like it
used to be even with as we said before
Disney you know
the orphan there's tons of orphans in
Disney but what are they that the
parents dead they're gone and like and
why because that was the broken family
and we have to come back from the broken
family and move on and stuff like that
but you know hey I don't think that ever
happened to much when those were made do
you know it's like most parents were not
dead I guess he didn't have two world
wars so maybe maybe that's part of it
too but but you know but as you know the
evil stepmother or stepfather whatever
it was more like hey finding that
traditional family value of MU Vuitton
stuff and now it's sort of like hey it's
not the traditional family that you know
you've heard about and you know happily
ever afters and stuff but you know
here's how you move on with that here's
how you still have a happy family and
you're content with yourself and because
I think we're just opening up more and
more to how many different kinds of
families there are in that relationship
you don't have to have the mother the
father and the two kids it could be a
father a father and a kid it could be a
single mother and two kids it can be
related to yeah it could be any like way
possible where before it was not
necessarily pounded in your head but it
was that kind of whole thing where it's
like you're supposed to have a mother
and a father and you're supposed to have
a brother a sister you know that's the
norm you know the nuclear family seems
to be I mean I don't think I'll ever be
like gone you know but it is certainly
something that it's like there's just so
much more variety of different kinds of
family which i think is just it's nice
because it's it leads to more variety of
people and leads to more variety of
understanding and opening up more
options and different mindsets and I
think that's really cool and I like it
that you know sort of these shows and
movies and stuff are addressing that
especially ones a.m. for kids yeah see
for me what the whole adoption thing
it's so 15 years go by of your life
you're living with this family and you
learn to love them and to learn to hate
them there's things you love about your
parents and there's things you hate
about them you know and it's always that
whole thing of when I run away it's
gonna be so much better and I think a
lot of people who are adopted it's that
whole fantasy of
I'm gonna meet my birth parents and
they're going to be rich or they're
gonna be famous or not gonna love me
more or you know they're not going to
gripe about my homework you know it's
that whole fantasy of they're just gonna
be better than what I have now and I
think a lot of times when they finally
meets that other person they don't live
up to that expectation I'm not saying
that they're scummy people it's just oh
no they're just normal folks and I think
more than seeing like like how finn is
and it sounds like in kimmy schmitt not
a really great mother I think we should
I would love to actually see more just
average people being met now yeah I'm an
awesome just like average people like
when I met my birth mom she's an average
person she's a completely average person
and she's got other kids and she's now
married you know it's tough and it's
just like oh okay
she moved on with her life and it was
it's fine there's no problems and I kind
of want to see that more that it's like
I keep in touch with her every once in a
while and we hang out every once in a
while but it's not this close connection
or no connection mm-hm and I think
that's a lot of what's going on now is
it's either your best buds or your
mortal enemies yeah it's I I think with
this being opened up more on you know
these shows and TV and stuff I think
that will be analyzed more I think cause
only now are we starting to get these
stories more frequently yeah and I think
on top of it it's just more dramatic if
you make them you know one or the other
it's yeah the parent you've always been
looking for all the bad scene is over or
it's not what you're looking for be you
know what we'll move on that's just yeah
that's great drama it's better right
away yeah running yeah but no I'm come
with you because I was can't thinking
that too I'm like I'm seeing a lot of
these stories about you know parents not
being what they thought they would be
I'm like yeah what would it be if it was
just a normal person because yeah I've
heard a lot of stories of people that go
and find their you know their birth
mothers and fathers and a lot of times
it's like yeah it's not what they expect
but it's like they're just nice people
whatever and you know where the
relationship goes from there you know
berries and stuff I've also heard ones
with
yeah but yeah it's one of those things
were it's like that would kind of be
nice just sort of like what connection
you know
would you have from that or just what
relationship would you build from that I
think would be very interesting so ya
know I you know I did just before we
leave because I don't know if we were
told this story when you did meet your
birth mom oh yeah well was it was it the
who was somebody saw suburbanite yet saw
Jory and Embry in there and then when
they met they're just like you know the
meeting family for the first time that's
just like wait a minute you're aren't
you from suburbanite yes well well how
did that work again okay so I meant I
met my birth mom and all that stuff and
it was on my son's 18th birthday which
was 9/11 9/11 but his birthday the 9/11
so I'll never forget that day a letter
in the mail and everything and we
finally met with her and then we I found
out I had three brothers I was like what
um so I met my brother Steve and boom it
was you know it only now did you notice
on the last ring but continue the story
um my brother Steve great guy I love
them and everything uh we're talking and
everything and try to remember how it
came up somehow it came up they like we
did videos with you it's pretty neat and
it's fun and all that stuff and Steve's
like uh-huh and my mom's like wait a
minute you know this he's like yeah I
watch him all the time like what what
did you tell me you never but like yeah
my brother in a sense has known me for a
while because of helping you out but
didn't know it was me like actually saw
you a lot yeah I never knew it was you
know just I think that's really really
freaking cool like no I think that's a
pretty face whoa
another one is my friend Todd I'd work
horror conventions with it and
apparently one of those conventions my
mom was actually at oh really
so again at some
one time I could have actually bumped
into her and Mattie or she could have
come up to our table and I never would
have known yeah small world it's kind of
creepy stuff like that so yeah that's
about it and but wonder I did love
really quickly one when Finn is walking
and it's the whole do I wake up now yeah
you wake up now now yeah and then just
like cut all dry face and the vulture
comes up oh yeah you've been locked for
like two days
really oh what's that over there no wait
ah darn it yeah I was gonna be is me
okay but again that when Finn gets to
the water he needs that water to live
pretty much to an extent and instead of
just taking it he stops and he asks ya
instead of like just going oh I need
this to survive it's like isn't okay
can I don't which is completely opposite
of his father who's taking that water
India and making demands and stuff like
that and he also as soon as he has it
like all the wrinkly like just go away
he's suddenly like back to normal so no
I just said the bolt the vulture Buzzard
just like yeah it wasn't like super it's
like I geez
so yeah good stuff and we will see you
on the next one which will be right
after this but not for you it will be
the next day but we get to watch it
right now
damn it why